he is the rights to Rocky which is
unfathomable it never happened before do
you kind of like make peace at a certain
point or you know you can't make peace I
mean let's be realistic here you can't
make peace when someone has been so
nefarious in my in my opinion so like
horrible how he got that I don't know
which means I have to beg him
that can I do this can I do that oh yeah
all your sons want to be producers sure
that's fine and the thing is I don't
care about the money I wanted to leave
it to my children so I can't forgive
them do you feel like I can never watch
Creed Three kind of thing never
like Michael B Jordan nice guy the
studio is wonderful but it's just the
it's been such a real rough emotional
ride that's all yeah and it really has
now if Michael B Jordan we come up with
a story I'll do Creed Four with him as
long as the other fellow is not involved
right